what if Shanks didn't stop kaido from
coming to Marine form what if the time
skip never happened and the crew
immediately went to the new world or
even better what if Luffy was captured
and sentenced to death well I researched
these topics for a long time and here's
exactly what would happen Okay so you
all know how kaido wanted to come to
Marine Ford and join the war thankfully
he was intercepted and stopped by Shanks
but what if that never happened what if
Shanks was too late to stop him firstly
let's see which side kaido would fight
on would he help the Marines and attack
Whitebeard or would it be the other way
around honestly I doubt kaido would join
any sides at all his only goal here is
to kill Whitebeard and if anyone else
tries to oppose him he will crush them
no matter who they are so how would the
battle play out now that there are two
Emperor Crews on the field the first big
change is that Blackbeard will most
likely not show up he is very cautious
about who he fights and with kaido there
he'd be terrified and wouldn't attempt
to pull anything off of course the
Marines would immediately recognize that
kaido is current a much bigger threat
than Whitebeard due to his destructive
nature still for now they'll wait and
observe immediately after joining the
war kaido attacks Whitebeard and the two
will clash in one of the most epic
battles the series have ever seen Marco
and other commanders would instantly
jump in to help their Captain but they
are stopped by the king queen and Jack
who tell them not to disturb kaido and
Whitebeard would be evenly matched and
their battle would create complete chaos
destroying half of the base in the
process we can assume that at this point
Luffy would rush in to rescue Ace and
unintentionally activate his conquerors
hockey shocking everyone on the
battlefield this along with the
destruction kaido and Whitebeard are
causing should be enough for Luffy to
come in and save his brother however a
kaneu immediately engages them and since
no one is around to help ACE dies
protecting his brother but as soon as
the Admiral tries to kill Luffy a strong
bust of hockey stops him in his tracks
of course it Shanks although he was late
to stop kaido he followed him to the
base he also brought this ridiculously
big subscribe button that you should
definitely click anyway he would try to
help Whitebeard but the latter would
refuse saying something like this is my
battle red hair don't interrupt me or
I'll kill you too Shanks would listen
and would not try to help him sengoku
would probably order Admirals not to
attack red hair Pirates and to wait for
their chance instead after a long and
fierce battle Whitebeard is completely
out of strength due to his illness and
kaido finishes him off with one last
attack having done what he came here to
do kaido would attempt to leave the base
but seeing their chance Marines would
try to intercept and defeat him while he
is still exhausted from his battle
Shanks would use this chaos to safely
leave with Luffy kaido and his
commanders would battle all the Marines
including GARP and sengoku what would
actually happen here is really hard to
guess but considering that the Marines
are at their full strength and that
kaido is injured I think they would
actually manage to bring him down there
are still three interesting scenarios
left to cover and the last one is
absolutely insane alright what would
happen if the time skip never took place
what if the straw hat Pirates reunite it
after only three days as they originally
planned would they still be able to
achieve everything they did or would
something much darker occur well for
starters they would obviously be much
weaker than they were in the original
story and they would have considerably
harder time in the new world I know what
many of you are saying now the
supernovas managed to survive in the new
world just fine and become somewhat
notorious Pirates since Luffy was one of
the strongest supernovas at that time he
should also survive the new world pretty
easily right well no that's completely
wrong and let's explain why there is one
important difference between Luffy and
other supernovas and you guess what it
is if you said that Luffy and his crew
consist of total idiots who don't have
the slightest sense of danger and would
attack anyone they want regardless of
consequences you'd be absolutely right
you see even though the new world is the
most dangerous sea with good planning
and organization you'd be able to avoid
all of the really strong enemies until
you eventually get stronger this is
exactly what some of the supernovas did
Hawkins literally uses tarot cards to
tell him the outcome of certain events
law became a warlord which made his
journey a lot easier and Vijay aligned
himself with big mom can you imagine
Luffy doing any of these things of
course not for example take the sabouti
archipelago Arc here Luffy punched a
Celestial Dragon with completely no
regard for consequences and Admiral is
coming for me excellent let him come of
course when kizarro actually came Luffy
realized just how weak he really was
against some of the world's most
powerful Fighters if Luffy came across
Emperors in the show's early stages he'd
probably challenge them too thankfully
he didn't based on all of this Luffy and
the straw hats have absolutely no chance
of surviving the new world they may be
able to leave Fishman Island alive but
as soon as they get to punk Hazard and
engage Caesar Clown they sign their
death sentence there is no way straw
hats can defeat Caesar without their
time skip training they couldn't even
use hockey back then and were
objectively much weaker so unfortunately
Luffy and his crew would die during this
Arc before we explain what would happen
if gear 5 Luffy was at Marine Ford let's
first explain what would happen if Luffy
was captured and sentenced to death by
Marines okay let me Begin by saying that
this would certainly start the biggest
war ever even bigger than Marine Ford
was although capturing an emperor pirate
like Luffy would be a dream of the world
government if they ever actually
attempted to do so it would backfire on
them heavily here are two important
things that Luffy's capture would
trigger and let me explain exactly what
those are firstly since there are many
countries that Luffy liberated this
would probably make all of them leave
the world government as a sign of
rebellion the government would have to
send CPO or some other group to quell
the Revolt but this would only worsen
things as the other nations would see
their true face with this it's possible
that even more countries would quit the
government bringing the world into a
state of chaos but this is not even
their biggest problem do you know how
many people would attempt to save Luffy
from the execution would you believe me
if I told you it was easily over 100
000 people just think about it straw
hats and the entire Grand Fleet red hair
Pirates the entire Army of alabasta Bo
Hancock and Kuja Pirates wano Samurai
remnants of Whitebeard Pirates all of
Fishman entire Galley law and Frankie's
family the entire revolutionary Army and
even GARP this would surely be the
biggest Alliance of forces ever made
although there are some notable Marines
like sengoku kizaru and akanu they would
be completely helpless even if they
execute Luffy before the alliance Comes
This would only make things worse for
them as it would be outright Mayhem in
the end assuming that all factions I
mentioned can work together the entire
Marine force would be crushed it's crazy
to think that one man alone could unite
all these people and overthrow the
entire government way back at Marine
Ford mihawk summarized this perfectly
it's not some sort of special power but
he has the ability to make allies of
everyone he meets and that is the most
fearsome ability on the high seas and
finally the moment you've all been
waiting for what would happen if gear 5
Luffy was at Marine Ford during Ace's
execution after Awakening his devil
fruit Luffy became one of the strongest
characters in the entire series but
imagine if he had these Powers pre-time
skip how would he stack against some of
the characters at Marine Fort and most
importantly would he be able to save his
brother Ace I will start by saying
something shocking I think gear 5 Luffy
is actually stronger than Whitebeard at
Marine for think about it Whitebeard was
already old and sick at this point he
had to be connected to medical equipment
at all times and had only a fraction of
the power and endurance he once had I am
only mentioning this to demonstrate how
influential gear 5 Luffy would be in
this fight okay so the battle would
start same as in the anime but
everything would change once Luffy falls
from the sky and joins the fun the first
major change is that Luffy would
immediately use conquerors hockey to
eliminate all weaker opponents so they
wouldn't be in the way remember how
Admirals were toying with Luffy and not
taking him seriously during this Arc
well that wouldn't be the case this time
as Admirals would definitely sense the
threat Luffy is posing so how would the
battle play out well I know many of you
are thinking that Luffy will just go
into god mode and wipe the floor with
everyone but let's be realistic here
Luffy is obviously incredibly strong but
he would be up against three Admirals
Warlords and even garments and Goku if
you want to stay alive these are
definitely not the enemies you
underestimate anyway Whitebeard would
also recognize Luffy's strength and the
two would assist each other firstly
whitebeard's commanders should be strong
enough to hold off some of the Warlords
and possibly one of the Admirals the
only warlord that would cause some
problems here is mihawk still
considering that he wasn't really
interested in fighting that much during
this Arc he probably wouldn't go out of
his way to stop Luffy or Whitebeard next
Whitebeard and Marco should easily hold
the remaining two Admirals and keep them
busy this would mean that Luffy's path
would be cleared and he'd head straight
for Ace his first obstacle would be GARP
and as was already implied in the show
GARP can't bring himself to seriously
punch Luffy so he'd probably just let
him pass the only one left now is
sengoku and this time around you'll be
much more serious fight against Luffy
with all he has so can Luffy defeat him
well don't forget that sengoku is really
old 77 years to be exact he is not as
fearsome as he used to be and since he
is a fleet Admiral he probably didn't
see much action in quite some time based
on this Luffy should be able to at least
injure him enough to escape with Ace but
not without some serious injuries wow
this is happening Whitebeard would be
stabbed by Squad which puts him and his
crew at a disadvantage also the entire
Blackbeard's crew will arrive to Ambush
Whitebeard and as in the original
version they will manage to kill him
enraged Luffy would engage Admirals and
heavily injure them but also sustain
further wounds himself by the time
Shanks arrives both sides would be
absolutely worn out unable to continue
fighting and the war would end with Ace
alive click on this video where we
explain 12 insane one-piece theories